[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Wer neulich den ZDF-Fernsehgarten geschaut hat,
hat bestimmt gesehen, dass ich dort diese Torte zubereitet habe.
Das ist eine Wickeltorte umrandet mit kleinen Gebäckröllchen.
Ich finde, das ist eine schöne Torte.
Ich habe sie beim ZDF-Fernsehgarten
anlässlich des Muttertages zubereitet,
aber diese Torte könnt ihr natürlich jederzeit zubereiten
und allein genießen oder auch verschenken
jemandem eine Freude bereiten.
Ich finde sie sehr schön
und vor allem ist sie von der Herstellung her auch nicht so aufwendig.
Wenn ihr nicht so geübt seid im Backen oder sagt,
es muss noch schneller gehen,
dann könnt ihr hier im Inneren die Wickeltechnik auch weglassen
und einfach einen ganz normalen, runden Biskuit backen,
die Torte schichten – dann geht es noch schneller.
Aber glaubt mir, selbst mit der Wickeloptik geht es auch sehr schnell,
denn so eine Biskuitplatte backt nur ganz kurz
und die Technik an sich ist schon recht einfach.
Ich zeige euch einmal den Biskuit.
Den muss ich jetzt zuerst zubereiten.
Für den Biskuit nehme ich 4 Eier, 1 Prise Salz, etwas Vanilleextrakt,
100 g Zucker und 100 g Mehl
und für den No-bake Boden 80 g Butter und 130 g Butterkekse.
Bei den Butterkeksen könnt ihr ganz normale Butterkekse nehmen
oder auch Hafer-Butterkekse, Cheesecake-Butterkekse...
Da gibt es ja mittlerweile auch ganz viele verschiedene Sorten
und so könnt ihr den Geschmack noch ein bisschen optimieren.
Den Ofen habe ich schon auf 210°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorgeheizt.
Die Eier sind schon zimmerwarm. Das ist auch immer ganz gut,
damit sich der Biskuit leicht aufschlagen lässt.
Salz und Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Der Zucker kommt noch dazu und dann könnt ihr die Masse
jetzt etwa 10 Minuten lang richtig cremig und luftig aufschlagen.
Falls ihr keine Küchenmaschine habt, nehmt ihr ein Handrührgerät.
Wenn ihr das Handrührgerät nicht so lange rühren lassen wollt,
könnt ihr auch einfach ein bisschen Backpulver zum Mehl geben,
also 1/2 – 1 TL. Dann geht euer Biskuit auch gut auf.
Aber ansonsten braucht man wirklich kein Backpulver.
Was ich in der Zwischenzeit machen werde:
Ich kann die Butter schmelzen und schon einmal die Kekse zerkleinern.
[Küchenmaschine]
[Musik]
Die Butter gebe ich jetzt hier dazu. Kurz verrühren.
Dann lege ich jetzt hier einfach eine Backfolie aus.
Einen Tortenring kann ich schon einmal auf 20 cm stellen.
Da füllt ihr jetzt die Masse ein und drückt sie flach,
entweder mit einem Glas, mit den Händen oder mit der Burgerpresse.
Dann kommt der No-bake Boden schon einmal in den Kühlschrank
und ich rühre solange die Biskuitmasse weiter.
Ich habe sie nur ausgemacht, damit ihr mich besser versteht.
[Musik]
[Küchenmaschine]
So sieht die Masse jetzt perfekt aus – schön weißcremig.
Jetzt siebe ich das Mehl dazu.
[Musik]
Vorsichtig unterheben.
Jetzt nehme ich einfach mein Backblech. Ihr wisst ja,
ich backe immer ganz gern im Backrahmen und in Backringen.
Ihr könnt aber auch ein ganz normales
herkömmliches Backblech von eurem Backofen benutzen.
So jetzt einfach auf die größte Einstellung,
die Masse einfüllen und glatt verstreichen
und dann sofort im heißen Ofen backen.
Bei Biskuit ist es ganz wichtig:
Ich habe es in meinem Grundrezept auch schon erwähnt,
dass der Biskuit ganz heiß gebacken wird, aber dafür ganz schnell,
damit die Biskuitplatte nicht austrocknet
und eben beim Aufrollen nicht reißt.
[Musik]
Bei mir backt der Biskuit jetzt 9 Minuten, kann aber auch sein,
dass er bei euch nur 8 Minuten oder vielleicht auch 11 Minuten backt.
Achtet einfach auf die Oberfläche. Diese soll schön goldbraun sein.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Guckt mal, die Backzeit nutze ich auch immer,
um dann direkt die weiteren Zutaten vorzubereiten.
Der Biskuit ist jetzt gebacken.
Jetzt könnt ihr ihn direkt herauslösen.
[Musik]
Dann ein sauberes Geschirrtuch drauf.
Ihr solltet den auch wirklich nach dem Backen direkt herauslösen,
denn die Backform gibt ja auch noch die Restwärme ab
und dann gart er ja im Prinzip noch weiter und wird trocken,
wenn ihr ihn nicht gleich herauslöst.
Noch ein sauberes Tuch drauf und dann einfach abkühlen lassen.
Da es jetzt wirklich ein sehr dünner Biskuit ist,
kühlt er sofort ab und ich kann schon direkt meine Creme vorbereiten
und mit der Torte weitermachen
– ist wirklich ein sehr schnelles Rezept.
Für die Creme nehme ich 500 g Quark
– ihr könnt einen Sahne- oder Magerquark verwenden –,
80 g Puderzucker, Vanillextrakt, 1 Prise Zitronenabrieb,
400 g Sahne und San-apart zum Steifschlagen.
Die Quark-Sahnecreme kennt ihr mittlerweile von mir.
Ich gebe jetzt den Quark in die Rührschüssel.
Ihr könnt hier auch statt Quark Mascarpone oder Schmand nehmen,
wobei Schmand ein bisschen flüssiger ist als Quark.
Also wenn ihr Schmand verwendet, solltet ihr mehr San-apart benutzen.
Ihr könnt auch Frischkäse benutzen.
Auf jeden Fall den Puderzucker dazu geben.
Da nehme ich auch immer Puderzucker und keinen Kristallzucker,
weil der Kristallzucker sich auflöst
und das Ganze auch flüssiger macht.
Deswegen ist Puderzucker in Cremes immer besser.
Vanille, Zitronenabrieb. Dann erst einmal kurz verrühren
und dann gieße ich langsam die Sahne dazu
und gebe teelöffelweise San-apart mit rein
und schlage die Creme steif.
[Musik]
So sieht die Creme jetzt aus.
Ich hatte sie auch kurz in den Kühlschrank gestellt,
damit sie schön kalt bleibt.
Ich habe hier alles gerichtet.
Zum Füllen nehme ich hier jetzt noch Erdbeeren.
Da habe ich bereits die grünen Stile entfernt
und jetzt könnt ihr sie einfach in Scheiben oder Würfel schneiden.
Ich mache das so.
[Musik]
Hier nehme ich kurz die Backfolie darunter weg.
Dann den Backring, den brauche ich jetzt erst einmal nicht.
Den brauche ich erst später wieder.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier meinen wunderschönen Biskuit.
Die Oberfläche ist jetzt unten. Das wird ja eine Wickeltorte,
d. h., ich brauche jetzt lange Streifen.
Diese messe ich jetzt ab, und zwar mache ich 6 cm breite Streifen.
[Musik]
Dann kommt jetzt hier die Tortencreme drauf.
Josh, kannst du es dir schon vorstellen? Noch nicht?
JOSH: Ich glaube, jetzt weiß ich, wie es wird.
SALLY: Schön glatt aufstreichen.
Ich nehme am Rand immer eine Teigkarte.
Dann habt ihr immer gleich alles bis zum Rand schön verstrichen,
ohne dass es überquillt.
[Musik]
Dann lege ich jetzt hier die Erdbeeren drauf
und achte aber darauf, dass ich sie nicht auf die Schnittfläche lege,
also hier habe ich alle 6 cm einen Schnitt.
Das könnt ihr nach Augenmaß machen
oder ihr könnt es noch einmal nachmessen
oder auch die Teige ein bisschen auseinanderziehen,
diese Biskuitstränge... Streifen? Stränge!
[Musik]
Jetzt könnt ihr noch ein bisschen Marmelade nehmen
und sie hier auf den Boden streichen.
Entweder eine Erdbeer- oder komplett eine andere Marmelade.
Jetzt wird hier der erste Streifen
wie eine Mini-Biskuitrolle aufgerollt.
Ganz vorsichtig!
Dann in die Mitte setzen und alle anderen Teigstränge drumherum legen,
sodass eine Spirale entsteht.
[Musik]
Ich drücke sie gern auch ein bisschen zurecht.
Ich sehe nämlich, hier fehlt noch ein Teil.
Hier hinten ist es schon komplett.
Dahin kommt der letzte Strang.
[Musik]
Da wird es hinten zu viel. Daher schneide ich ihn hier jetzt weg.
Damit die Torte schön ihre Form behält,
setze ich hier noch einmal den Ring außen herum.
Ziehe es schön fest. Der Biskuit ist auch schön locker.
Hier oben gern auch ein bisschen herunterdrücken
und die restliche Creme verstreichen.
Ich habe auch noch ein bisschen Creme übrig.
Aber die Oberfläche muss jetzt auch gar nicht perfekt sein.
Also wenn ihr da keine Creme mehr habt, ist es gar nicht schlimm.
2-3 EL hebt ihr euch auf jeden Fall noch auf.
So kommt die Torte jetzt erst einmal abgedeckt in den Kühlschrank,
am besten für 2 Stunden, damit sie auch wirklich schön fest wird.
Wenn ihr nicht so viel Zeit habt, dann lasst es mit der Wickeloptik
und backt den Biskuit einfach rund,
denn der Biskuit ist jetzt praktisch die Spirale
und die sollte sich jetzt erst einmal setzen.
Wenn ihr die Zeit nicht habt, dann backt ihr ihn rund,
schneidet ihn auf und füllt die Torte einfach.
Dann könnt ihr nämlich direkt nach 10-15 Minuten Kühlzeit
schon mit den Keksen außen herum weitermachen.
Aber ich nehme mir jetzt die Kühlzeit.
Dieses kleine Stückchen vernaschen wir gleich.
Die Torte ist jetzt kalt und kann fertig dekoriert werden.
Für die Dekoration benutze ich Röllchenkekse
und werde diese in Kuvertüre tauchen und ihr könnt jetzt entscheiden,
welche Kuvertüre ihr nehmen wollt – ob ihr weiße, Vollmilch,
zartbitter, Karamellkuvertüre oder Ruby nehmen wollt.
Ich nehme die Ruby-Schokolade.
Das ist ja neben den anderen die vierte Schokoladensorte.
Ich finde sie einfach schön, weil sie leicht fruchtig schmeckt
und es passt ganz gut zu den Erdbeeren.
Deswegen, denke ich, passt sie ganz gut.
Ich nehme jetzt hier die Ruby-Schokolade
und habe hier etwas Kokosfett zum Schmelzen.
Dann die Gebäckröllchen und noch Erdbeeren zum Ausdekorieren.
Also bei den Gebäckröllchen könnt ihr die Röllchen
oder Löffelbiskuits nehmen, oder andere Süßigkeiten,
die so eine längliche Form haben,
was eben auch hübsch an der Torte aussieht.
Jetzt kann ich die Kuvertüre schmelzen.
Dafür habe ich hier schon Wasser kochen lassen.
Der Herd ist jetzt aus. Das ist auch immer ganz wichtig,
damit die Kuvertüre jetzt nicht zu heiß wird.
Gerade Ruby-Schokolade ist da ein bisschen empfindlich.
Jetzt habe ich 2/3 meine Kuvertüre in meiner Schmelzschale,
denn diese wird temperiert, d. h., 2/3 werden geschmolzen.
Das sind dann so ungefähr 50°C,
aber ihr braucht da auch kein Thermometer.
Mit dem Thermometer ist es natürlich immer ein bisschen besser,
aber ohne Thermometer ist diese Methode, die ich anwende,
also die Impfmethode, eigentlich ganz gut.
2/3 der Kuvertüre über dem Wasserbad schmelzen
und dann das restliche Drittel einrühren.
Dann hat die Schokolade einen schönen Glanz,
hat eben nicht diesen grauen Schleier
und hat die perfekte Weiterverarbeitungstemperatur.
[Musik]
Wenn sie geschmolzen ist, einfach die Kuvertüre vom Wasserbad nehmen
und das übrige Drittel einrühren.
[Musik]
Hier kommt jetzt noch das Kokosöl mit rein.
Dieses bewirkt, dass ich noch einmal einen schöneren Glanz habe
und dass die Kuvertüre aber auch nicht mehr so knackfest wird,
denn die Torte soll ja später auch gut angeschnitten werden können.
Daher sollte sie jetzt nicht mehr so fest sein.
Jetzt kühlt die Kuvertüre durch das restliche Drittel wieder ab,
auf etwa 26-27°C, und ich muss sie noch einmal kurz draufsetzen,
damit die Reste wirklich komplett schmelzen.
Dann ist sie so etwa bei 32°C,
aber wie gesagt, ohne Thermometer klappt es ganz gut mit den Angaben.
Dann habt ihr sie perfekt.
Hier jetzt wirklich nur kurz, ungefähr 30 Sekunden,
bis alles geschmolzen ist – dann ist sie perfekt!
[Musik]
Sucht euch jetzt am besten schon einmal eure Tortenplatte aus,
setzt die Torte um.
Ich mache das immer gern, wenn der Tortenring noch dran ist.
So kann man sie nämlich einfacher bewegen. Kurz mittig setzen.
Dann den Ring entfernen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier noch ein bisschen Creme übrig.
Diese streiche ich an den Rand.
[Musik]
Den Rest einfach hier obendrauf.
Das muss jetzt auch gar nicht schön und sauber sein.
Jetzt sind die Gebäckröllchen an der Reihe.
Diese werden jetzt mit der Spitze in die Kuvertüre getaucht,
etwa 1/3 bis 1/2, und dann mit der Kuvertüre nach oben
an die Torte drumherum gesetzt.
[Musik]
Immer kurz abtropfen lassen und dann dransetzen.
So sieht die Torte jetzt aus.
Ihr denkt euch jetzt: Wow, das hat genau gereicht.
Ich habe es mir ausgerechnet, wie viele Röllchen ich brauche.
Einfach den Umfang der Torte ausgerechnet,
dann den Durchmesser der Röllchen und anschließend addiert;
es waren ungefähr 350 g. Aber es kommt natürlich darauf an,
ob ihr Löffelbiskuit oder andere Kekse nehmt.
Jetzt wird die Schokolade schön fest, weil die Torte kalt ist.
Ich stelle sie trotzdem ganz kurz in den Kühlschrank
und kann in der Zwischenzeit die Erdbeeren vierteln oder halbieren.
Die restliche Kuvertüre
– ich habe jetzt natürlich nicht so viel gebraucht,
wie ich geschmolzen habe,
aber die restliche Kuvertüre könnt ihr weiterverwenden,
ihr könnt sie noch einmal festwerden lassen
oder ihr könnt Rocky Rolls daraus zubereiten,
also diese kleinen süßen Teilchen,
die auch immer eine tolle Resteverwertung sind.
Oder wie gesagt, ihr gebt sie jetzt einfach in ein Gefäß,
lasst sie festwerden und könnt sie später weiterbenutzen.
So mache ich es auch immer ganz oft, wenn ich Schokolade übrighabe.
Später sieht es dann so aus,
aber wenn man sie dann schmilzt, ist sie wieder völlig normal.
[Musik]
Jetzt könnt ihr die Torte einfach ausdekorieren,
d. h. die Erdbeeren drauflegen oder gerne auch andere Früchte,
mit Ruby Perlen dekorieren und dann ist sie fertig.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr noch ein Geschenkband drumherum wickeln.
Das ist mir aber ein bisschen zu verknittert. Ich bügle es kurz.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Torte fertig und kann probiert werden.
Komm, du kleine Quatsch-Maus! [Lacht]
SARAH: Hallo. Die ist wunderschön!
SALLY: Wer bist du? Stell dich mal vor!
SARAH: Ich bin Sarah, die Quatsch-Maus.
Die ist sehr schön geworden. Gefällt mir gut, vor allem mit dem Band.
SALLY: Rede weiter, Rede weiter, überbrück die Zeit.
SARAH: Mit dem Band, das du super wieder aufbekommst
und wo überall ein süßes kleines Sally draufsteht,
in Rosa, so wie die Ruby-Schokolade. Gut so? Tadaaa!
SALLY: Tadaaa!
BEIDE: Aww, schön!
SARAH: Drip.
SALLY: Schön, gell?
Der Anschnitt wird jetzt natürlich abenteuerlich.
SARAH: Das wollte ich nämlich vorhin schon sagen.
SALLY: Aber nicht wegen den Röllchen, sondern wegen den Erdbeeren.
SARAH: Ich bin gespannt, wie sie innen aussieht.
Habe ich schon einmal eine Wickeltorte gesehen?
SALLY: Nein, der Josh auch noch nicht.
Es ist nicht meine erste Wickeltorte, aber eure erste.
SARAH: Das hört sich immer so an wie bei einer Baby-Shower-Party.
SALLY: Eine Wickeltorte! Stimmt, Windeltorte!
Ah! [Lacht]
SARAH: Ja, aber manche machen da so eine Windel-Wickel-Torte.
Dann dachte ich vorhin... Pampers drin? [Lacht]
SALLY: Jetzt verstehe ich, warum du verwundert warst.
Und ich habe das nicht verstanden!
SARAH: Ja, jetzt weißt du es. Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Hast du das nicht im Buch ? Im Backbuch.
SALLY: In dem, was du fotografiert hast, nicht, oder?
SARAH: Da war nur Schachbrett. [Sally stimmt zu]
Doch, die Oreo! [Sally bejaht]
Guck mal, mein... !
Doch, die Oreo-Torte war Wickel.
SALLY: You’re a brain! [Sarah stimmt zu]
Josh, sag es auch bitte!
JOSH: You’re a brain! Sarah, the brain!
SALLY: Sarah, the brain cake Tester.
Der Rand ist gerade weggefallen.
SARAH: Trotzdem bin ich gespannt.
SALLY: Der erste Schnitt ist schwierig.
BEIDE: Uuuh! [Lachen]
SARAH: Mit Erdbeeren drin auch.
SALLY: Ay jo, aufgewickelt!
SARAH: Ay jo! [Beide lachen]
SALLY: Der erste Schnitt ist schwierig. Danach wird es schöner.
SARAH: Sieht schön aus.
SALLY: Willst du das allein essen?
SARAH: Ja.
SALLY: Okay. Tschüss! [Lacht]
SARAH: Nein, ich stelle sie in unsere Mitte.
SALLY: Ich finde es cool,
weil normalerweise sind Tortenböden immer waagerecht.
SARAH: Crunch-Boden! [Sally stimmt zu]
Crunch-Boden ist mein Favorite.
BEIDE: Mmh! Mmh!
SARAH: Ist das Quark?
SALLY: [Lacht] Hmm!
SARAH: Ist das Quark? [Sally stimmt zu]
Quark, gell? [Sally stimmt zu]
[Lacht] Ich habe geraten.
Aber voll lecker! Schmeckt mir gut!
SALLY: Du hast geraten, gell?
SARAH: Ja, aber gut. Ich wusste jetzt nicht, ob Mascarpone oder Quark.
Ich habe irgendwas gesagt.
SALLY: Hast du aber gut gemacht. Sehr gut.
Ich finde es auch gut. Und ihr könnt sie ja füllen, womit ihr möchtet.
Also jetzt gerade ist die Erdbeersaison.
Deswegen nutzt die Erdbeerzeit gut aus.
Aber ansonsten finde ich diese Wickeltechnik echt cool.
Sie würde sich einfacher schneiden lassen,
wenn ich nicht so einen Berg voll Erdbeeren draufgelegt hätte.
Muss man schon sagen.
SARAH: Aber sieht halt schön aus. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Der zweite Schnitt wird besser.
Ihr könnt die Torte auch gern nachbacken.
Vielleicht habt ihr sie beim ZDF-Fernsehgarten mitgebacken.
Dann dürft ihr hier gern eure Fotos zeigen.
Postet sie einfach, markiert mich drauf.
Dann sehe ich das auch und kann alles wieder reposten.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken.
Das Rezept findet ihr auf Sallys-Blog.de oder in meiner App.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
SARAH: Tschüss!
SALLY: Gut, gell?
SARAH: Sehr gut, aber...
SALLY: Jetzt ist die Sonne leider weg.
Jetzt können wir nicht mehr raus.
SARAH: Egal. Die macht Sommer im Kühlen.
SALLY: Ich spüre die Sonne.
SARAH: Ich spüre sie auf dem Teller.
[Musik]